[Musique]
80 km au nord-ouest de Nairobi Au
Kenya le lac naiva sere Au cur de la
vallée du
ri classé parc national le lac est une
réserve précieuse
de souvent dans rar en africa l'eau
Douce en quantité est un atout important
verser le niveau de vie de
populations elle permet aussi le long
des rives le développement de la culture
avec un effet pervers qui dit culture
dit engrais et qui dit engrais dit
souvent
pollution ainsi les eaux du lac naiva
subissent les conséquences d'une
activité agricole au complet
développement prix victime les poissons
et les noms de ceux qui contribuent
la ville des biodiversités
lac